[Music]
hi
i'm vickie boykas i'm a machine learning
engineer
at automatic the company behind
wordpress.com
but today i don't want to talk about
machine learning or data
what i do want to talk about is building
a digital garden
and i want to explain why this is
important by talking a little bit about
what my daily routine looks like
in the longest year of our lives in 2020
and i'm hoping that as a data scientist
it extrapolates and generalizes to what
everybody's environment looks like and
what we can do about some of that
so my day usually starts around three
o'clock in the morning
that's when my youngest son wakes up
he's very little
so i usually have to put him back to bed
and wait on him to settle down
and while i'm doing that i do my
favorite activity which is doom
scrolling through twitter
nothing's really changed on twitter
since the last time i read it
maybe three four hours ago but it
always makes me feel worse coming away
from it than i do
going into it and so i'm filled with
this endless anxiety of
news items that have happened so then he
settles back down
i go back to sleep but in the meantime
i'm woken up around four o'clock in the
morning by a text message from my state
which is an alert to be careful of covid
for the hospital restrictions to keep
masking
and to be aware that the rates in our
area are on the rise
this is kind of helpful information but
not really because
it also makes me feel more anxious than
relieved
and it brings me more questions than
answers really
for example when's the next time i'll
get to see my elderly relatives
will school stay open for the next
couple weeks or so
how are we doing as a country and when
will it get better
and of course none of us can answer that
so i'm left feeling even more anxious
of course by the time all that's over i
go to the numbers
i look at the covert tracking project
which is a really wonderful project
put together by a group that tracks
totals across each state
although it doesn't make me feel any
better either even though there's very
good information because
the covid rates are on the rise it's
exponential and
it doesn't seem to be ending anytime
soon so by the time that's all over
it's usually around seven o'clock in the
morning which is when my
older child my daughter wakes up and she
also has a lot of pins and needs uh
usually hers are more like
what hippopotamuses eat and what are the
phases of the moon
so i help her get ready and get dressed
and then we go downstairs to breakfast
breakfast i use the term very loosely
because as a family with small kids it's
just
pretty much chaos so during that time
i get some time to catch up on what's
been going on at work
i usually don't have 99 slack
notifications
but since we do work in a distributed
remote and asynchronous way there's
usually someone working
all around the world even when i'm
asleep so there's definitely writing and
reading to catch
up on so when that's all over i go to
my favorite part of twitter to catch up
on which is data twitter
and it seems like overnight there have
been five million more data analyses
published
10 million more new deep learning
frameworks
and 15 million more data controversies
and
it's a lot to keep up with and i feel
like i never can
so it all adds to the compounding
anxiety
of the things that i have to keep up
with in 2020
so after being pinged on warning and
exposed to the stressful world of 2020
durham covid and the amplification of
that world in my digital media
i start hearing not the individual noise
but the steadiest stream
of radio kfkb radio kfkd is a concept
anne lamott talks about in her wonderful
book about the creative process bird by
bird
lamat says that kfkd plays for all
creative people
she says there's two speakers the left
is the noise that you hear when you
think you're better than everybody else
and the right is the noise when you
think you're worse than everybody else
and i count data professionals data
professionals
within creative people too because we
have a lot of technical work that we
have to do
and a lot of very uh judgmental based
work that is more of an art form than a
science
today we're living in radio kfkd but
over top of that
is the pandemic so it's what i like to
call radio 2020.
the right speaker is everything we've
mentioned the noise of other people's
perfection on social media
the noise of controversy of amplified
fears
of heightened everything a platform that
is constantly on
and a black mirror that reflects our
worst fears and beliefs
the left speaker is all the news we're
constantly processing about living in
uncertain times
and over top of all that is the never
ending static
of the pandemic that won't end fears
for us and our loved ones constant
restrictions
and when we needed the most isolation
being isolated is hard enough as a human
being isolated and bombarded by the
radio of 2020
the noise of clickbait doom scrolling
constantly being surrounded by
information that is largely negative and
impossible
so what can we do about all of this well
we can't really change our physical
space we can't change the state of the
world right now
we can't change the people that rely on
us
we can't change the human interactions
that we have
what we can change is the digital world
that we operate in
and so i want to talk a little bit about
what the aspects of that digital world
are
and how we can change it why is radio
2020
so good at derailing us and why is it
constantly creating noise for us
there's three reasons first of all is
that online it's noisy
and this has been the case since even
before 2020.
in a conference that i attended and
spoke at sceptec
several years ago one of the speakers
that really stood out to me
was natasha dauschel who is a
sociologist
and professor at new york university
and she wrote a book called addicted by
design
that was talking about all the different
ways that our online universes today
are a lot like casinos
the summary of her research is that much
of the online world
particularly social media companies much
like casinos are designed to draw our
attention away in small bursts
as a result to get our attention and
retain you on the platform
sites often do things like send you a
combination of mobile alerts
notifications
and emails sometimes this engagement is
good
like if we're discovering interesting
blog posts or donating to creators or
watching original content
but oftentimes it can simply be noise
the online noise interferes with our
ability to concentrate on longer term
projects
and engage in longer term thinking and
the problem is that there's always new
noise
and always new content online
a second problem with this content is a
lot of it is very superlative
what do i mean when i say superlative
usually
you only get the very worst or the very
best
because that's what actually filters
through the noise and creates engagement
so as an example if someone is posting
their pictures of
vacation online although not recently
these days
but if they are you'll usually only see
the best pictures for the
hotel room you won't actually see how
they were late
for their flight or um had problems at
the airport or had transportation issues
you only get the highlights and the same
is true with all the worst news stories
of 2020 especially because those are the
ones that are optimized to get us to
click
so we'll only see the very very worst
and we won't see
what's progressing more in the median
and in the long term
the third problem is that online is
worse in the context of the current
state of the internet the enormous
amount of additional pressure 2020 has
put on both of our physical and digital
lives
has pulled us apart as humans which
means that we can't meet with anybody
and we're left to face the crisis in the
context of the current state of the
internet on our own
so we have this crisis that's occurring
both
in the physical world with everything
that's been happening during the
pandemic
and in the digital world with a crisis
for our attention as well
how do we fight this one of the best
ways that i found personally
is to be able to control it a very small
bit of the time
and the best way to do that is to build
your own digital garden
and lamont in bird by bird says that the
best thing to do
is to take it piece by piece and the
title of the book
comes from a book report that her
brother had to write
30 years ago she writes my older brother
who was 10 years old at the time
was trying to get a report on birds that
he'd written
that he had three months to write it was
due the next day
we were out at our family cabin in
bolinas and he was in the kitchen table
close to tears surrounded by binder
paper and pencils and open notebooks by
birds
immobilized by the task at hand then my
father sat down beside him
put his arm around my brother's shoulder
and said word by bird buddy
just take it bird by bird the idea is
that we can't change
everything but even changing a little
tiny bit of our environment is better
than changing nothing
so what's the way that you can fix the
world and change it bird by bird
the best way to do that is by planting a
garden
the secret garden is a book by francis
hawks and burnett
who lived in america in england in the
19th century
the story is about a girl named mary who
the parents die in a cholera epidemic in
colonial india
it's kind of sad but her parents never
saw her much anyway
she was cared for by servants and as a
result she had grown spoiled selfish and
extremely lonely
she sent to england to her uncle's
estate on the moors
the moors are a beautiful lonely and
foreboding place
and just like the moors the house where
mary stays is dark and cold
as is often the case in british
literature full of secrets
it's revealed that mary's aunt who died
had a secret garden in the house that
was then locked up
when mary comes to the garden it's
neglected she begins to tend to it and
in the process of caring for it
and watching things grow she forgets to
feel sorry for herself and her parents
the process of caring for it brings her
back to life
so right now we're all a little bit like
mary
at the start of a garden that's fallow
we're lost
we're not quite sure what to do so
there's some things that we can do
and i next i want to talk about things
that people have done
and then end with some suggestions for
maybe smaller things that you can do to
get started
so how do we fix this how do we create
something that's for
our public garden and makes the internet
better at the same time
i'll talk about a couple of different
ways that people in the community have
done this and that i've done this
and then offer some more lightweight
suggestions
if these seem overwhelming to you the
first and best way
in my opinion is to write something from
your perspective
david robinson has a really good blog
post about this um he writes a bunch
about statistics in r
as well he said that if you write
something if you
tell somebody something three times then
you should write a blog about it
and he says that it's important to write
a blog uh for
a data science career portfolio and i
think it's important not just for that
but because it allows you to create
something that you're in control of on
your own platform
that doesn't change and that counteracts
the way that social media works
and that you can come back to again and
again and have it always be the same
you can write about anything from
analytics
from your opinion on certain trends
certain packages you've done
so these topics have been written about
hundreds of thousands of times before
data analysis
and tidy verse but the important thing
is that it's coming from your
perspective everybody comes to the story
with a completely different perspective
completely different set of life skills
and history and work skills
and the internet wants to hear about
them two really great recent examples of
this from our blogger
are this recent article about pipes
about the pipe tool and a spoonful of
hugo how much hugo do i need to know
neither of these are very long and
complex topics
but they break down what you need to
know in very specific ways
and they're talking about it from the
author's experience
so these are both fantastic the way that
i've done this
is in a couple of different ways one of
the places i'm active on
is my technical blog and
i write about machine learning and data
and metrics
my main goal in my blog is to write
about things that i don't really see
anywhere else on the blogosphere
or write them from my perspective and
the other thing is that in the process
of writing
more technical posts you get more
insight into what's going on and a
better understanding as well
so some things i've written about are
getting machine learning to production
um the spark api
using r and in a very serious
examination breaking down the ios screen
time report
none of these are breakthrough topics in
particular getting machine learning to
production
is a topic that has been covered over
and over again
but this is my take on the topic these
are things that are interesting and
important to me
and now i have them to refer back to in
my blog
another place i've been writing is my
newsletter normcore tech where i
look at machine learning and data but
more from a human-centered perspective
i started again because i didn't see
anyone covering these topics in quite
the same way
sure we all talk about google and
facebook and social media
every week but there were things that i
wanted to understand better
so here are some recent things i've
talked about how a lot of the products
that we use
are built by consensus by an average of
10 000 people in san francisco
and what impact that has for our online
world
what happens when the internet stops in
the country as it did in belarus
in the middle of 2020 and how the
internet actually gets from country to
country
and how google drive which is ubiquitous
in most of companies i've been at
is actually production because we store
really sensitive data in there
and when it goes down it can be a
problem
another interesting thing that happens
when you write about things that are of
interest to you
is you start getting people who are also
drawn to these topics
so when i first started my newsletter i
didn't get any emails
but then slowly and surely i got more
people talking to me about these topics
from their perspective as well
so it's a wonderful way for building a
community even if you didn't initially
intend it to be
the second way if you want to go a
little bit of a more technical route
is to empower people to understand data
data literacy these days is really
really important with how confusing and
clickbait oriented the internet has
become
and anyone who helps make sense of that
data and make it trustworthy
is a superhero a fantastic example of
this is the work of julia silagi
who has created books courses and writes
on her own blog about topics like tidy
tuesday
as well as showcases videos she does a
fantastic job of
explaining and making it accessible and
has that content on her site to own
another wonderful example is the our
ladies sydney course
created by lisa williams who was
inspired by her own frustrations of
getting started with r
the course goes through getting started
packaging and our markdown
and it's another great way to work
through what you're interested in
as well as share it with other people
another person who has done
a wonderful job empowering people from
the python community this time
is mantani who works in the natural
language processing space
on the python package spacey and not
only does she have clear explanations
how to use the package she open source
a whole library that allows her allows
you to create your own course
finally cultivating your own garden can
simply be about being human and creating
connections
my one of my favorite examples about
this is the illustrative work
of allison horst who creates
illustrations both for her own talks and
for use in the art community
and they're just beautiful they're fun
they're interesting
and they're creative ways to think about
a topic that hasn't really been covered
in the same way before one of the
recurring themes of normcore tech my
newsletter
has been that even though we all sit in
machines and write code or munch data
for a great deal of the day
we ultimately crave human connection as
we do during this pandemic in isolation
we don't have a way to hand off physical
things especially now
cultivating our own garden that's not
subject to the radio frequencies of
radio kfkd is a wonderful way to do that
but what if you're overwhelmed by the
idea of getting started and don't know
how
there's a lot of really small ideas that
you can draw from as well that don't
necessarily involve
creating a course or making videos or
creating your own blog
and so i want to cover some of those
things as well
if you're feeling intimidated by these
very large-scale
broad-ranging projects there's
much smaller ways to get started and in
fact one of the ways that i got started
was by creating a blog and drawing memes
something like 10 years ago
and i've been hooked on content creation
ever since so there's some much smaller
ways that you can approach things
one of the first things you can do is
just make a commitment to write
200 words once a month the most
important thing
is that you're writing in a space that
you
feel comfortable writing and that is not
an impediment as an employee of
automatic i can recommend wordpress.com
but it doesn't really have to be that
just any place where the technology is
not impeding you
for making small progress on a bunch of
words every day
the second thing that you can do
is share a piece of code if the idea of
blogging seems overwhelming
sharing code and talking about code can
be a stepping stone to cultivating an
online place of your own it's extremely
easy to mark write markdown posts in
github
and as an added bonus is
learning an industry tool that's very
widely used something that i started
that i copied from simon willison
is a directory called til today i
learned full of random code snippets and
pieces
the benefit of this is that you come
back to it again and again
i know that's true for me and you won't
lose it and you have it for others to
share as well
in a world of incomplete stack overflow
answers think of this as your stack
overflow that's filled with your
specific questions and answers
for your needs you can also make a comic
it might not seem like it but memes
comics tick tocks
and the like serve is a really important
part of content creation
and i should know my twitter feed is
chock full of them just because
something isn't serious
doesn't mean it doesn't have educational
value or importance
as content i'm thinking specifically of
the wonderful designs that julia evans
puts out that include things like
learning linux and get
but in a fun way you don't have to
create even an entire sign even a fun
meme about our statistics or drawing
like alice and horsts
are all great ways to share what you
know and feel like you have some sort of
control over the creative process you
can also do something like make a bot
which is what i did if you like and have
the opportunity to write code in your
spare time
building a bot based off of an api is a
fun way to learn about how the web works
and claiming your little piece of it a
few years ago i built something called
soviet art bot
which as it says on the tin scrapes wiki
art for socialist realist images
and tweets them out once a day i learned
a lot during this process
but what i love about it is that i get
to control my online environment through
code
i'm creating and changing what people
see on their timelines
art is something i always appreciate on
my twitter feed
and as a traditional bonus it gave me
the time to learn about twitter apis
and cloud computing paradigms
the three things that i just talked
about are very tangible ways but there's
also very intangible ways to do so
the first one is sending an email
appreciation either an email
or a note on github or a comment on
someone's blog
it can be to the author of your favorite
art package someone you're working with
or
just someone you've seen do cool stuff
online people love getting appreciation
and an increasingly negative and
polarized world that kind of feedback is
really hard to come by
you might even get into a conversation
with the author about something and
create something together which has
happened to me before
what i love about this especially with
the email aspect is that it's private
but it's still a way to send out really
great positive energy out in the world
and finally start your own community
one of the reasons that we feel
overwhelmed is that big communities are
intimidating
i've often talked about this theory i
have called good things don't scale
where one of the reasons we get stressed
out about social media
is that humans are not meant to carry
out as many relationships as are in
dunbar's number
150 people we simply can't hold it in
our heads
and so we lose context with all the
conversations we have
the best way to fight that noise is to
create a small community
that can again be in any medium as long
as it's a medium that you
and the other people in the community
keep up with for example if you know you
hate text messages
use signal or whatsapp the ideal
community for this
is under 10 15 people
and these people should be fairly active
a community of like-minded people who
support each other is the key to
fighting the bigness and the noise of
the internet
because the process for caring for a
garden is an important one
and it's a long-standing process and
it's made up a very
large broad range of multiple things
every time you create something positive
you're doing a small amount of work
outshining all of the negative work in
the world in the internet today
you're taking away one piece of noise
one ping from your life
there are many reasons to do it
including the ones i talked about at the
beginning of the talk
but mostly for me personally it's a
wonderful way to manage my own
20 20 anxiety and change the world bird
by bird
because when you're attending to a
garden a thistle cannot grow in that
place
as france as hogs and burnett writes and
maybe that's just as much of a reason to
create a garden as any other
it's my hope that radio 2021
is going to be tuned to a much much
better frequency than radio 2020.
thank you so much for your time and i
hope to see your digital gardens
soon
[Music]